how much boy TJ Dillashaw both our boys
yeah it's not good you see his apology
yeah I did what you think well I mean at
least he's just straight up admit I
think that's what you have to do because
then you're kind of yeah I fucked up
then people can't really come at you
yeah I mean he's being honest about it
and oh I do have to correct something he
someone wrote an article that said that
Cody Garr Brandt found out the TJ tested
positive for his fight - and Cody went
crazy I think I got duped by a clique
beta article but we all got duped
everyone thought that and actually I got
us with a clique baby article and
everyone did but I should have been more
responsible so my apologies to TJ so
they have I don't think there's a been
another one that they tested him on that
he's positive but they're looking into
it now here's the thing well we have to
this is something that I know
EPO is not always tested for correct and
she Dana
what'd he say because you saw his
expensive hiss fuck you asshole on you
guys aren't yet he didn't know he goes
you guys aren't tests for EPO every time
we paid this much money and for you
numbnuts to show up guys at 3 in the
morning and test them you're not testing
every time when we paid this much here's
I had no idea yeah well time to cancer
usaba thanks boys thanks boys thanks for
playing see ya everything's been looking
good you have to take it from here come
back be cool bro yeah next thing you
know everybody's back looking thick and
juicy now but they still I guess what
they're gonna do is they're gonna go
back and see if they still have the
samples for when he did beat Cody and
test those for EPO well this is what you
and I were talking about where we're at
the store when like how far do we go
back dude I'm telling you Joe you don't
want to go down there tamal your crazy
ass tamal let's find out what's real why
why you want to do that you're crazy
dude you can't you can't do it you're
gonna ruin the foundations of the UFC
this is a intellectual exercise I don't
really want to test them all yeah but if
I was gonna argue
and I'd say test tomorrow I think line
it up what's find out what's up we've
always wondered half we'd not be test
for some reason and Stephan Bonnar
you'll see just tomorrow that this the
fight that catapulted the begin test
you'll see this but but then again
test all the football players test all
the best everyone's feelings for me to
watch screwball
did you watch screwball no I have it
holy shit is it good Billy the Billy
Corbin document do you know what they
did yeah though they had little kids
play a rock it's crazy right it's
hilarious story the story's nuts because
it's in the people who were actually
there narrating it there they're telling
the story and they got these little kids
playing a rod and playing the Riddler
it's fucking great man crazy story it's
a crazy story I feel bad for TJ men you
know what man
when everybody makes an agreement to not
cheat and they're testing you all the
time to try to make sure that you're not
cheating don't you think that the
environment is different now than it was
before you saw it it was instant was
initiated and don't you think that's a
good thing I'm putting words in your
mouth knows how to phrase that question
yeah it is better overall for the purity
of the sport I think it's better but I
still assume guys are gonna figure out a
way to cheat yeah because because peds
in sports is no different than than a
referee or a judge or gloves they go
hand in hand
people have always done peds or
enhancements within every aspect whether
it's football basketball music surfing
SAG's it's just what humans do
especially when the odds are so high
that this little thing can help you
achieve maybe it gets you a victory but
you know and then also with with TJ
Dillashaw is then granted we know EPO is
illegal but this is this one's a little
different tested positive for like
steroids or whatever it's like
straight-up steroids because if you and
I engage in a fight and we have eight
weeks to Train and you go to Mount
Everest or where the fuck you want to
get your red blood cells higher and then
fight me back at sea level but I just
stay here inject those red cells you
know the difference is that if you
operate at sea level and you're taking
EPO you will be able to work much harder
and get more rounds in and you'll
recover much better if you are up at
altitude the problem is living and
training really at high out so you can't
put out as much output but the night of
the fight we're gonna have the same know
why the EPO will have more labor yeah
not even close
no your get you you have a stroke from
that stuff I'm Eden Africa right depends
on how much you're taking yeah that was
one of the things Nowitzki was telling
me about her young cyclists thick that
were just having strokes well your boy I
think it's Lance Armstrong that maybes
on your show but he would wake up mill
night and had to have to ride a bike
another so thick that was my friend
salami do I know Swami
no no explain okay I think you know I'm
saying like it like it like racer you
have to tally up in the middle of the
night yeah right Lance did discuss how
guys think that's where I got it yeah
it's been we've talked about it
maybe Lance did did Lance talk about
having to get up and run it you and I
talking actresses did I talk about get
up in the middle of night riding a bike
no I'm just kidding no just kidding Oh
but anyway obviously look that with the
Lance Armstrong thing I feel like
everyone was doing it and you don't
everyone you know everything you have
something you think TJ is the only one
no I think other people are taking EPO
and they're hoping they don't get caught
that's what I think I think it's still
cheating correct and I think I don't
think everybody's doing that I think
there's a lot of guys who were doing it
honorably
I agree most guys are doing it honorably
you know I think you could get it in
your mind
look I don't this it just is what to
take from max Holloway it is what it is
right it is what it is what it is it's
cheating right he would TJ would admit
that I'm sure he did a minute yeah he
did that's what it is but I mean I don't
even know if have a point I don't know
if I do either but it's but it's the
guys trying to I was gonna say the guys
trying to provide for his family but so
is ever since Kody Garber so his car
Yarbrough so is Henry cejudo
so is everybody everybody he fights but
I would like to sit down with TJ and
I've reached out them since he's been
suspended I want to sit down with him
strike why would you why did you do it
like what led you to this because his
card has been great since he was a child
with his wrestling background
now what point along the way was it six
years ago six fights ago did you think
you need to do this in order to beat
these guys
well let's we could look at one thing
that we know that he's been doing he has
a rigorous strength conditioning program
that training with that drink
auditioning program that he's doing you
have an issue with that I understand
your issue but that shit is off the
charts crazy difficult they're doing
wild stuff and Madison bar work and
plyometrics and all this stuff and TJ
looks like a fucking beast when he's
doing it have you seen Brian Ortega's
work out with with his with Mike yeah
they do crazy shit - yeah yeah yeah yeah
I mean I'm not justifying it but what
I'm saying is that in order to do that
kind of work like to put out that kind
of pace your body's gonna have to have
some time to recover in between workouts
well if you take EPO that time of
recovery is diminished quite a bit
according to Nowitzki you're saying it
allows guys to put in more work so it
doesn't just give you more cardio it
allows you to recover faster so you
could train harder and you know as well
as anybody that sometimes the difference
between victory and defeat is just
having a little more in your gas tank
just having specially at that a little
longer camp and I'm not being injured
the last couple of weeks we lost some
cardio
you know those awful feelings well if
you have the opposite of those awful
feelings of not instead of being
compromised being enhanced air - it's
gonna help you then flee exactly it's
gonna help your head you get to come in
there like a fucking champion